g60 est très simple je suis diabétique
m'arrange pour être autonome le plus
possible mais ce que je devrais faire
essayer me pencher aller en dessous des
lits loppsi offert de l'eau chiche
portable ferai mon lit ça demande trop
d'efforts de 1000 euros puis laver mes
planches et le reste jusqu'à prendre ma
rage depuis mars
yvette royal n'a plus dead pour son
ménage et ses courses
les mesures de confinement ont bloqué le
soutien extérieur qu'elle recevait d'une
préposée embauché par une entreprise
d'économie sociale dans l'est de
montréal
nous on ne peut que en ce moment et
délais très vulnérable des vénérables
les entreprises d'économie sociale qui
assure des services essentiels au
maintien chez elles des personnes âgées
et fragiles ont dû faire des choix
cruels
c'est à dire prioriser 550 personnes sur
12000 dans l'île de montréal depuis la
mi mars
un monsieur qui est quadriplégique qui
est dans sa chaise roulante qui mangent
à la paille qui ne peut pas sortir de sa
maison pour aller faire sa lessive à la
buanderie cette personne là en ce moment
je ne peux pas la desservir
on s'entend que l or cet usage est là un
besoin
et quand ils nous appellent ça nous
brise le coeur je l'éteins 4 est encore
julie jean lang tous trouve chanceux de
pouvoir compter sur budget cinq matins
par semaine des services qu'il se paye
depuis plus de deux ans vous prépare le
mieux avec une envie et puis c'est le
petit déjeuner c'est c'est mon principe
aéroports le nonagénaire viennent
d'apprendre qu'elle a postulé pour un
emploi en ch est celle d une décision
qui tape vraiment vraiment pas facile à
prendre
vraiment pas j'adore mes criage proche
avec un rocky
sauf que j'ai besoin d'un petit peu plus
j'ai besoin de passer ma famille à moi
le futur de ma famille et moi aussi
les entreprises d'économie sociale ont
donc encore plus de mal à garder leurs
employés qui sont tentés de doubler leur
salaire
on peut pas faire avoir la même force de
frappe dans mon et ça dans mon
territoire avec 22 employés à temps
partiel que 5
en temps régulier voilà qu'elle apprend
qu'elle n'aura plus l'aide alimentaire
hebdomadaires qu'elle recevait d'un
organisme communautaire le pourquoi je
sais pas enfin que j en avais besoin
pour manger un autre coup de pouce qui
permettait de préserver son autonomie
ici anne louise despatie radio canada
montréal